bonjour à tout le monde
d'abord je veux remercier aux
organisateurs de cette journée de donner
la parole à belize ans je pense que
c'est pour nous c'est rare de parler un
public pareil et vraiment on est très
très fiers de participer aujourd'hui à
cette journée
quelle est l'importance pour vous la
nourriture quelle importance à
l'agriculteur pour vous quelle
importance à la terre pour vous est-ce
que moi agriculteurs paysans quitterait
50 vaches
est ce que j'ai encore le droit
d'exister ou est ce qu'on veut dans
l'avenir uniquement des exploitations
industrielles des vaches des
exploitations avec millevaches 200
vaches 300 vaches des poulaillers des
cochons
est ce que c'est ça la nourriture que
vous voulez manger
est ce que c'est ça l'avenir de
l'agriculture
ou est ce qu'on choisit encore une
agriculture familiale une agriculture
paysanne
les vaches dans les champs des cochons
dans les champs des poules
il y a deux possibilités soit on se bat
pour notre métier ou soit on arrête
l'exploitation
aujourd'hui pour produire un litre de
lait ça me coûte à l'exploitation 45
cents
si je ne compte pas ma main d'oeuvre
c'est 33 cents et aujourd'hui je reçois
de ma laiterie 24 25 cents
et on annonce déjà un prix de lait de 20
cents
qui de vous est prêt à travailler sans
salaire
qui de vous et près de se lever tous les
matins samedis dimanches jours fériés
produire de la nourriture d'une qualité
énorme le lait sans salaire et même sans
arriver à couvrir ses coûts de
production
notre métier on aime le métier pour être
agriculteur il faut l'aimer c'est une
passion mais aujourd'hui il y à une
tristesse je pense que vous ne pouvez
pas vous imaginer une dépression des
suicide dans le monde agricole au
travail dans les champs au travail avec
les bêtes
comment est ce que vous voulez faire ce
travail correctement
si vous ne gagnez pas votre vie comment
est ce que vous voulez produire de la
nourriture de haute qualité
c'est tous les jours on doit amener de
l'argent
s
moi j'ai plus de place je pense que oui
on a fait des manifestations peut-être
beaucoup entre vous vous rappelez de ces
images cette image de tristesse en 2009
on a fait un épandage de lait de 3
millions litres de lait sur un champ à
ciney on a fait des manifestations à
bruxelles on a déjà balancé du lait sur
le parlement européen
on a bloqué les villes et je sais
parfois les citoyens il se pose la
question mais ces agriculteurs avec les
gros tracteurs pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
viennent nous emmerder c'est clair on se
bat pour nous mais je pense qu'on se bat
aussi pour vous cette agriculture
industrielle favorable aux
multinationales ou banques
je pense que on ne doit pas la soutenir
on va continuer à faire des
manifestations mais pour nous
l'importance c'est pas que faire des
manifestations attaquer les politiques
qu'il veut plus de régulation de la
production libéraliser les marchés et
les jeunes qu'est ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui il construit des étables %
vaches pour 200 vaches pour 300 vaches
et après qu'est ce qui se passe bien ils
sont en faillite
et qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya des
investisseurs qui reprennent ces
exploitations qui reprennent ses terres
et l'agriculteur il reste aux cours sur
son exploitation comme esclaves pour ces
gens là alors il y a le choix soit on
continue à manifester ou peut-être aussi
nous aurons doit changer un petit peu
notre mentalité parce qu'on est
responsable aussi nous les agriculteurs
mais si on veut avoir un prix du lait
qui couvre les coûts de production
ea salaires il faut changer aussi nous
mêmes et on a mis beaucoup d'énergie
dans les manifestations mais je pense
aussi maintenant depuis cinq six ans on
a dit il faut réfléchir il faut sortir
du système
on a mis une coopératif en place où il
ya aujourd'hui 500 agriculteurs dedans
on a mis la marque fait rebelles dans
les grandes surfaces
et aujourd'hui c'est la journée de la
rébellion
si vous réfléchissez un petit peu fait
rebelles ça veut dire aussi fait
rebelles
parce qu'on a perdu le contact avec vous
on a perdu le contact avec le
consommateur
on s'est contenté de rester chez nous à
la ferme et produire mais sur toute la
vente
on l'a laissé la vente aux
multinationales à nestlé danone campina
lactalis n'importe comment il s'appelle
et aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'ils ont eux
ils n'ont qu'un plaisir qu'aujourd'hui
ils peuvent acheter la matière première
le lait le moins cher possible pour que
il peut faire du bénéfice énorme alors
vraiment pour nous c'est très important
d'avoir le contact avec vous on a besoin
de vous soutenir
mais on ne s'est pas contentée dé sa una
avec la surproduction aujourd'hui qui
existe en europe
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec on le fait en
poudre et on l'exportent dans les pays
tiers dans les pays pauvres
moi j'ai été deux fois au burkina faso
et j'ai vu là-bas comme nous les
producteurs belges
les producteurs européens on est en
train de détruire toutes les petites
agriculteurs là bas qui essayent de
nourrir leur famille ils ont une vache
il joue deux vaches et alors nous on
arrive avec notre peur avec notre poudre
de lait à des prix tellement bas que il
n'arrive plus survivre
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui on
détruit les exploitations familiales en
belgique en europe et en même temps on
détruit tous les exploitations dans ces
pays là et là bas on est en train de
créer les migrants qui vaut venir dans
cinq dans dix ans parce qu'aujourd'hui
ils ont encore quelque chose' l'eau du
lait ils ont à manger mais si on
continue cette évolution la main dans
l'avenir eux ils sont obligés d'arrêter
ils n'ont plus rien à perdre et qu'est
ce qui va se passer
il va venir ici ils vont venir ici en
europe parce que ils disent ouais mais
vous vous avez du lait vous avez vous
gagné beaucoup d'argent
et pour ça on a décidé de faire le même
projet qu'on a fait en belgique on va
lancer dans un mois ce sera officiel
ferrer faso le lait équitable
mais uniquement entre les producteurs
c'est à dire on a fait une coopération
entre les producteurs belges et les
producteurs du burkina en direct sans
passer par des organisations vraiment
pour que hilary fille qui arrive à
garder et à arriver à survivre aussi
chez eux
alors on a dit pour notre coopérative où
va aller encore pas plus loin ça ne sert
à rien que vous vous acheter nos
produits etc afin nous ordonna le
bénéfice non on a dit on va l'ouvrir
l'agriculteur aux citoyens et
aujourd'hui j'ai entendu déjà plusieurs
fois le mot qu founding nous on appelait
ça chaos funding parce que à partir des
2 puis il ya trois quatre mois chaque
consommateur il peut acheter des parts
chez nous à la coopérative
les citoyens ont droit à participer aux
assemblées générales
on va ouvrir un mandat dans notre
conseil d'administration de la
coopérative pouvoir avoir cette vision
supplémentaire des consommateurs et
aussi ça c'est un projet unique européen
les agriculteurs les citoyens dans la
même coopérative et j'espère que si ça
vous intéresse
regardez sur notre site internet fai
rebelles point b 1
devenez membre et dans l'avenir le lait
qui vous avez chez vous à la maison le
fromage que vous avez chez vous à la
maison vous pouvez dire ça c'est aussi
ma coopératif alors je veux arriver à la
fin se battre pour nous les agriculteurs
tout seul ça ne marche pas on a trop peu
de poids les politiciens ils sont
tellement dans la main des
multinationales des banques que vraiment
nous les agriculteurs paysans ou non
nous vend plus on ou non vont plus il
veut que des exploitations industrielles
et pour nous la grande phrase c'est
quand l'injustice devienne une loi
la résistance devient devoir merci